12 يوما مرت على هذا الزلزال والامل ما
زالت قائمه في العثور على نجينا تحت
الانقاض تواصل فرق البحث التركيه والدوليه
اعمالها في ست ولايات من اصل احدى عشره
ولايه منكوبه جنوب تركيا نتابع جديد هذا
الموضوع من شانلي اورفا مع مراسله الجزيره
سلام خضر اذن سلام يعني كثير كثيره هي
المهمات
الملقاه على عاتق فرق الانقاذ ما زالت حتى
الان اضافه الى محاولات العوده بشكل او
باخر الى الحياه الطبيعيه والتاقلم مع
واقع جديد خلفوا هذا الزلزال
صحيح حسن كما قلت هناك ست محافظات لا تزال
اعمال البحث والانقاذ مستمره فيها خاصه
وانه بعد مرور اكثر من 260 ساعه تم انتشار
صباح هذا اليوم شخص لا يزال على قيد
الحياه في هاتاي المحافظات الست توازيها
خمس محافظات اخرى تم انتهاء العمل تم
انتشار جميع العالقين تحت الانقاض والان
يستمر العمل في رفع الانقاض تمهيدا لبدء
ما قال عنه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
بانها ستبدا عمليه اعاده الاعمار بدايه
الشهر المقبل في المحافظات المتضرره العمل
الاغاثي يسير ايضا بالتوازي مع عمليات
الكشف على المباني غير المتضرره هناك اكثر
هناك عشرات الالاف من المباني غير
المتضرره ولكنها تحتاج الى عمليه ترميم
هذه كلها ستسير بالتوازي حتى هذا الشهر دي
تنطلق المرحله الثالثه والاساسيه من اعاده
الاعمال بدايه الشهر المقبل العمل يسير
على اكثر مستوى بالضبط حسن اليوم كان هناك
اعلان بان الجامعات في الولايات المتضرره
ستعود للعمل على عبر شبكه الانترنت ليس
هناك من امكانيه لعوده الطلاب الى
جامعاتهم ولكن التدريس سيستانف
عن بعد في هذه الجامعات ايضا هناك عمليه
الاغاثه وايصال المواد الضروريه والاساسيه
للمتضررين هناك ايضا مساله اعاده اسكان
هؤلاء المرحله الاولى تم اسكان من اضطروا
لترك منازلهم في خيم مؤقته في مخيمات
اقيمت في المدن المنكوبه ولكن بحسب ما
علمنا هناك توجه لبدء استجلاب منازل جاهزه
خاصه مع استمرار فصل الشتاء في تركيا
وتوقع هطول الامطار في الشهر الثالث
تحديدا الحكومه تحاول تحسين مستوى
العائلات التي تركت منازلها في هذه
الاثناء حسن شكرا لك سلام حضور مراسله من
شانلي اورفا